[Music]
okay so you are a four billion year old
meat robot yep
you heard me right in fact as you're
made of 38 trillion cells and each of
those have their own task you're a robot
made of trillions of mini robots
you are a mega meat bot and your mission
for the past four billion years or so
and for as long as you keep playing this
game of life is to safeguard the code to
duplicate it to pass it on the thing is
you're rubbish at copying your own code
every time it's copied errors crop up
not good when an error makes a robot
worse at surviving but sometimes a
mistake helps them survive and they pass
that glitch in the codon that's
evolution in a nutshell right which
means you're not the result of some
fancy design I'm afraid you're a result
of billions of years of bad copies go
you another reason you're not totally
awesome is because that megabot of yours
often breaks down fortunately
cardiologists immunologists
microbiologists all the ist's have spent
centuries figuring out cuss sensors and
wiring so if something does go wrong
they can usually fix it where they
struggle though is when the machinery
turns on itself when a copying error
leads a cell to start dividing
uncontrollably to grow and multiply into
a tumor that's cancer and sadly even
with the might of our modern medicine
some cancers evade treatment but this is
where a new band of biologists step into
the story
the synthetic biologists these bio
hackers are mashing up science medicine
and engineering to rewrite the code and
fix the unfixable
biohackers are going into a patient's
genetic code and reprogramming their own
immune system to recognize cancer cells
and destroy them
it's called car t-cell therapy and it's
awesome see you're constantly under
attack by pathogens single-celled
bacteria viruses and fungi
despite deciding back in the day to stay
so no and not Avengers Assemble like you
did those pathogens see you in all your
mega meat BOTS glory as a fortress right
for the plundering thankfully you've got
a security team in place to battle these
invaders your immune system and some of
its top guards are your white blood
cells they trawl the darkness that is
your inner space checking the IDS of any
cells they pass although they're not
named badges but rather protein
fragments on the cells surface called
antigens there are two types of these
guards T cells and B cells T cells check
those antigen IDs using special Clause
receptors that lock with a particular
antigen if they find a match they attach
and they release toxic chemicals that
burst open the invading cells membrane
their b-cell workmates create antibodies
loads of small proteins little claws
that worked perfectly onto a particular
antigen marking them for destruction
these two comrades have got your back
and your immune system is brilliant at
spotting and fighting perfect ins that
invade from outside however they're not
so good at spotting your own cells that
have gone rogue the antigens on
cancerous cells don't look weird they
look a lot like your own cells and the
T's and bees aren't programmed to attack
them
the usual way to deal with cancer is to
try to cut the tumor out or turn to
radiotherapy and then chemotherapy to
destroy or block the growth of cancer
cells but if it's a blood cancer if it's
floating around your whole body you
can't do that and if the blood cancer
actually starts in your white blood
cells those key guards in your immune
system you'll really struggle to spot it
that's the case with acute lymphoblastic
leukemia and that's where car t-cell
therapy is kicking butt the bio hackers
are reprogramming a patient's own immune
system to recognize particular antigens
those particular protein fragments on
the cancer cells to do it you first
leave millions of the patients t-cells
then to get a t-cell to do something
different you need to replace its normal
code with something new something you've
designed
what synthetic biologists can now do
with DNA is super cool they use a
computer to put together their own
sequences of bases the chemical letters
that spell out the DNA there may model
what that new genetic code will do on a
computer and then make those sequences
on a DNA printer yeah that's a thing
printing not with ink or with a plastic
polymer like in a 3d printer but with
those fundamental building blocks of
life with those A's and C's and T's and
G's the new code they designed for a
t-cell has three key instructions one it
tells it how to recognize and kill a
cancer cell more specifically how to
modify an antibody what the B cells make
to attach on to a target antigen the
antibody is modified to make a new
receptor that can detect the particular
antigens on the specific
- it tells it to make copies of itself
when it finds that cancer cell and three
it tells it to survive in the patient's
body to get this new code into the
patient's t-cells you use a vector
something that will easily infect the
t-cell and carry that bespoke DNA in
with it and voila one cart ISA the name
comes from a fire-breathing monster from
ancient Greece that had a lion's head a
goat body and a Serpent's tail it was
called chimera a name that has now come
to be used for something that contained
two or more different types of tissues
or cells as this newly engineered cell's
genetic code is part t-cell part
antibody it's a chimera and it goes in
search of the cancers antigen using its
new receptor
before you put them multiplied up T
cells back into the patient you give
them a mild dose of chemotherapy to wipe
their existing t-cells then you simply
reinsert them now modified T cells the
car T cells and they follow their normal
DNA programming to move and search
however thanks to their new butt-kicking
code they've changed what they're
looking for they're now on a mission to
find the cancerous cells and destroy
them unlike conventional chemical based
drugs that get used up or excreted from
the body pretty quickly car t-cells are
living drugs to stay in the patient's
bloodstream for years that's a huge Pro
the flipside is that they're expensive
each car t-cell treatment is bespoke to
the patient and it's more difficult to
get them to work with common cancers
like breast or lung because you need a
specific antigen on the cancer cells for
the car t-cell to target and it's much
easier to find that in blood cancers it
still early days though and there's an
exciting future for car T cell therapy
researchers like dr. Martin Poole and
his team at UCL are working on improving
the Leukemia and Lymphoma treatments
even further and there's recently been
some promising work on solid cancers
thanks to car T cell therapy the
survival rate for B acute lymphoblastic
leukemia has improved hugely nearly all
patients go into remission which means
that the Leukemia cannot be detected
anymore and most patients stay in
remission biohacking is here and it can
reprogram your own genetic code to
enable your mega meet Bob to do things
it's never been able to do before
[Music]